[Musique]
avec robert d'automne et avec roselyne
c'est dodier bonsoir bonsoir on va
parler d'immobilier dans un instant mais
j'ai une question pour robert de tonnes
qui veut se prononcer sur 3 ap robert
l'aide fédérale était je présume assez
essentielle est-ce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui dans ce qui s'est passé
convient d'assurer l'avenir de transat
et je pense que ça permet à prendre et
d'aller chercher on parle pour le
consommateur c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais il reste 3 190 millions pourraient
se donner les liquidités pour faire face
à la situation c'est pas un des
problèmes de mauvaise gestion ou de
problèmes de mauvais plan d'affaires les
avions volent pas alors un vraiment une
relation particulière sur la décision du
gouvernement fédéral donc je pense que
c'est une bonne décision aussi pour
l'entreprise mais j'irai pour
l'industrie il devra le faire pour
d'autres si on a parlé de westjet
il devra le faire pour la saine
compétition devrait pas qu'air canada se
retrouve le seul compagnie aérienne au
canada comptant pour là confie de sang
qu'est monsieur stage a dit que monsieur
péladeau est un monsieur très
intelligent et il semble avoir de bonnes
négociations avec lui ça regardait du
côté de monsieur péladeau
oui c'est regarder mais je suis un peu
surpris que monsieur stage chez soi
avant c'est comme ça il ya des
discussions mais savez une entreprise
publique attire des discussions ça
relève du conseil d'administration le
conseil d'administration doit nommer un
comité spécial de membres est dépendant
qui vont embaucher des à blizzard ou des
conseillers légaux et financiers pour
analyser leurs coûts les autres pertes
est même chercher 2 à o s'assurer que on
reprend la meilleure décision au
bénéfice des actionnaires des
actionnaires l'édition financière mais
aussi au bénéfice de tous j'insiste
toutes les parties prenantes et là
dessus monsieur péladeau a sûrement une
longueur d'avancé puisqu'il garantit
conserver siège social c'est 5000
emplois 2.3 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires
une belle équipe de direction une belle
entreprise je pense qu'elle va trouver
preneur puis il faut s'assurer toutefois
que le siège social demeure au québec
ok on s'en va sur le logement puis je
vais commencer avec vous rose l'insee
sur l'enjeu du logement monsieur legault
s'est fait malmener sur la question des
prix des logements
il était choquée de la façon qu'on avait
interprété ses propos je vous le fais
entendre par pressage vous faire réagir
aux outils vois certains articles
aujourd'hui qui laisse entendre que je
parlais de 5 600 $ pour une famille
c'est qualifiable s'est pas très bien
passé qualifiable ceux qui ont écrit ça
parce qu'ils savent très bien
ils savent très bien que c'est parce que
je lui dis je parlais les étudiants bon
alors on a senti que monsieur legault
était affecté de la façon on avait
entendu ça certains laissant entendre
qu'il était un peu déconnecté s'est
connecté nous roselyne c'est qu'est ce
qui se passe est ce qu'on est dans une
crise du logement et des loyers
on est dans une crise du logement et des
loyers je pense que personne peut dire
le contraire qui est ce qu il faut faire
attention c'est avec le gouvernement
c'est que des fois il reconnaît qu est
ce qui se passe sans vouloir utiliser
pataky vrais mots donc si capable de
reconnaître effectivement qui manquent
de logements bordas
que les prix sont vraiment le
pourcentage est trop élevé pour les
mêmes les ménages le juste pour ce logis
une reconnaissance quand même look une
situation mettons qu'on devrait
s'occuper lation l'appel paul la crise
au pis c'est pas d'hier non plus parce
que au début des années 2010 rappelons
nous il ya une grande vague de
gentrification dans les quartiers où des
lits l'arrondissement ouvriers l'heure
si on parle plus de montréal comme
hashtag à maisonneuve le sud ouest avec
l'arrivée des jeunes professionnels les
et les personnes qui venaient de
l'extérieur pour travailler dont le
logement était pays
après ya eu un bienne be ça s'est
exacerbée au cours des derniers mois
mais on peut pas dire qu'on n'était pas
au courant de cette situation là étaient
présents et l'oeil au moins de logements
abordables mais est ce que c'est un
petit problème un moyen problème est ce
que ça prend des petits ajustements
ouste une crise importante ça prend des
gros ajustements roselyne sais je
voudrais continuer juste réagi robert
ensuite mais tout à fait il s'agit
vraiment de il ya quand même urgent cela
et à agir parce qu'une fois que les gens
quittent la ville
une fois qu'ils ont plus de place où
habitait que d'autres personnes prennent
possession des logements etc
c'est difficile de revenir à l'arrière
on veut pas vu non plus à san francisco
il ya quelques mois par exemple à
montréal où ce que même les travailleurs
de la ville ne pouvait pas habiter le
centre ville donc quand on chasse la
classe moyenne qui peut pas habiter le
centre urbain ya vraiment un gros
problème qui oui oui on peut on peut
dire la pandémie la pandémie peut avoir
le dos large c'est vrai qu'il ya plus de
200000 personnes qui ont perdu leur
emploi et donc au moins de revenus pour
les logements mais bien seul appui à
tous ceux qui avaient accès et besoins
des logements abordables ainsi avant la
pandémie
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
présentement qui est en train d'éclater
robert qu'en pensez vous ben moi je suis
assez d'accord avec ce fait mais le mot
urgence que rosine et à utiliser
je pense est bon même si on prépare les
d'urgence de logements abordables
on nous met cassés de l'enjmin mais pas
de façon abordable c'est différent on
veut ramener des gens montréal aussi
mais c'est très difficile des gens de
revenir à montréal
ce qui m'inquiète je pense que vous
devrez par préoccupation c'est que si on
veut qu'on
des logements d'ailleurs c'est très long
à l'heure actuelle dans ce qui se passe
dans la gérer la bulle immobilière le
coût des matériaux de construction fut
pas juste le bois en écrit cité asmat
est en consultation avec une entreprise
dans le secteur de la des matériaux de
construction
c'est incroyable la rareté de produits
si le manque de tu vois une habileté
alors déjà définitivement on est en
situation on va arriver dans une crise
je pense que le gouvernement doit
prendre soin aussi évoqué alors il doit
faire quoi le gouvernement roselyne sais
je vais vous donner quelques suggestions
gel des loyers
est ce qu'on doit aller leur hausse
dénoncée pour le moment je pense que ce
serait une bonne idée parce que il ya
présentement pas de mesures comme talent
pour régir qu'est ce qui se passe avec
les propriétaires et donc quand on sait
qu'à la régie du logement il ya tête
juste 1 % des logements 1 présentement
que les prix sont réguliers donc il ya
99% des logements qui ont vois même pas
pourquoi les sites augmente et chez
terra les propriétaires ils ne prennent
pas en soin de leur bâtisse souvent et
peu importe le prix ce qui arrive c'est
que il va avoir des gens les prix et la
qualité le jeudi rennes parce que il ya
des gens qui les occupe quand même il ya
des gens qui vont payer quand même donc
le problème est là donc s'il ya des gens
qui payent qui les occupent
mais après c'est les gens qui n'ont pas
les moyens ou qui trouvent ça insalubre
bain et ont pu place donc vous est
ouverte aux jeunes des loyers est ce
qu'on doit les leurs - soient couverts
ou à un plafond pour les deux prochaines
années donc 2021 2022 parce qu'il faut
dire qu'à 21 brabham inquiète beaucoup
de beau qui sont déjà signés il faudrait
carresser seychelles publié quatre
points de pourcent d'augmentation des
loyers à montréal c'est énorme
quatre mois je suis très très au delà de
ces deux années passées à vie puis plus
élevé que les années passent et ça c'est
inquiétant dans un un ménage c'est le
coût moyen de 1000 $ ça veut dire au
dessus de 420 dollars c'est de l'argent
après après avoir payé l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est ça donne beaucoup beaucoup
de pression moi je serais plus d'accord
avec un espèce de plafonnement ou moins
au coût de la ville pour les deux
prochaines semaines et que pensez vous
d'un registre robert des loyers pour
contrôler les augmentations comme le
demande la ville de
real écoutez moi je trouve que c'est on
voit un peu trop loin
je pense que ça pourrait aussi je moi je
vais te regarder ce qu'est ce que les
propriétaires vont faire on dire de
toute façon ils vont trouver les moyens
pour justifier des hausses qui veut dire
de façon le gouvernement vont payer
je trouve ce lourd dans cette gestion là
je serais assez froid assez prudents aux
caisses la ville de montréal veut faire
un peu renforcé sa loin que moi ce qui
le préoccupe beaucoup au général oui
c'est le fait que il ya les loyers sont
aux cons il ya souvent des taudis
souvent des propriétaires qui ont pas
rénover leur logement depuis très
longtemps il nous sort des nouveaux
arrivés son pont fait du marché à eux se
trouve qu'on est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup trop tolérant avec eux
et là je me prenne le waouh je mettrais
un mauvais mécanisme de supervision avec
beaucoup beaucoup plus de dates le mode
offert aux jeunes c'est présentement ce
qui vraiment être fait le cil une
responsabilité collective donc que les
promoteurs s'assure de mettre le
pourcentage nécessaire en ces veilles %
le de logement abordable que en fait les
personnes les propriétaires aussi soit
un peu plus un acte l'ours qui fixent
leurs prix de loyer parce que avoir le
droit à la ville c'est la base le c'est
de pouvoir ce logis présente mars et
polka merci beaucoup il était
passionnant vous allez dire aubert vous
avez trois mots logements sociaux on en
parle on en parle on en parle
il se passe rien on n'a pas des sommes
quand est ce qu'on va avoir une séance
de coupage de ruban pour l ouverture op
sièges
après la copie de jeu pas ok on en
prendra merci robert merci roselyne
sujet à des missions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit